[Music]
the population of New York City
is is staggering 8.3 million people one
out of 38 Americans lives in New York
City meaning there are more New Yorkers
than vegetarians in the United States
this populous city fits on 303 square
miles if everyone in Manhattan was on
the ground level there would only be 20
feet between people Nashville for
comparison has more than 50 times the
space and Manhattan nearly doubles in
population during the work day leaving
just half the space more people ride the
subway daily in New York then there are
people living in Los Angeles even more
mind-blowing at this very second there
are more people in the New York City
subway than live in Boulder Colorado
but the subway is much larger than you
would think if the tracks were laid
end-to-end they would stretch from the
city of foldable slices to the Capitol
deep-dish New Yorkers spend three times
the national average on rent and when it
comes to Chinese food they use 100
million takeout boxes a year that's more
takeout boxes than American homes
occupied by homeowners it is large but
this best city is actually only the 18th
most populous city in the world though
it may not be the biggest city to New
Yorkers it feels like the center of the
universe
Wow